European Union they are they are talking
about banning not only porn quite all
kinds of you know sort of quote-unquote
offensive material and a lot of this is
coming out of Denmark but it would it
would obviously span all of the European
Union and it's hard to say what is porn
what is offensive who's gonna decide on
all this stuff I can't start with you
Adam because I know
desi who should decide what is
pornography you know they're doing this
because they're actually they say that
they want to protect the image of women
and stop yeah I think they called it and
eliminate gender stereotypes that demean
women they're like oh really so you're
gonna born
you're gonna born you're gonna ban porn
because it's worked so well in Muslim
countries exactly right you don't get
some of that sexual stuff out it's
fertile ground that's going to increase
their or elevate the status of women in
that society and that's just [ __ ]
yeah do you do you think it's just an
endless slippery slope that no matter
what you do to kind of curtail
pornography or offensive images that
automatically nothing good can come out
of this because you just keep going well
I think that the definition of
pornography is the problem I mean the US
Supreme Court has tried and they said
well you know I know it when I see it
and that was determined to be not good
enough of a standard really when you
think about the expansion of internet
porn for example so you know I again
it's I understand the idea behind what
they're trying to achieve with this but
it's the absolutely wrong mechanism
because there's no way to understand
who's going to define it how they would
legislate how they would enforce it you
know there's so many issues that yeah
it's a slippery slope but it's just a
also I think a boondoggle of enforcement
absolutely people yes I'm totally not in
favor of banning of porn in any capacity
that is a very hard to find it's who
we're gonna be like get rid of the pole
who wants to ever get rid of the point
but I will say that there is something
like for example Iceland is the country
that's really leading this charge and
Iceland is taking note from how China
bans from users from visiting certain
website they don't want to use the same
software that is not a country we should
be following no please we should ever be
emulating ever China and then on top of
that the country or the party that is
supporting or is against the ban of porn
is the pirate
party from Sweden like how ridiculous
yeah does it happen anyone take anybody
series no wonder Europe's in such I'm
wait Matt favorites artists horn we
could call the pirate party called the
pirate party that's ridiculous Iceland
Iceland is the is the one that shrinkage
there that was I wasn't your joke about
shrinkage but I'm not gonna do that now
because ya did the discharge I'm gonna
go intellectual with you on this one
what do you think that maybe the
European Union is actually too big
because the people the sexual hang-ups
they may have in France may be very
different from the ones they may have in
Belgium or in Iceland etc etc so that
may be you can't legislate for this
giant no I yeah you know what I will
have to take together like I think that
obviously you know porn there's a market
for it
it doesn't some other people people need
it it's a release it's a fantasy
it is what it is but there is a certain
element where there is a dark dark dark
elemental porn where like it's like you
know teenage kids you know Bob or
bondage or girls getting [ __ ] on or
whatever and like that I think that that
might make it a point here - much there
is there is an element of like okay it
becomes less artistic and more just like
and that's you have to be careful with
that you know the cross is the legal
line not illegal I mean of course
underage is illegal but if someone wants
to get [ __ ] on they have the right as a
citizen of at least the United States to
make a film so I think it should be the
same in the European Union I do agree it
shouldn't be European Union but if the
goal is to protect the children then it
just don't keep the kids out of porn
right don't book don't do porn with
children there isn't like there is
underage porn
I think obviously that's no one you know
then that's if that's the goal then to
get rid of the underage form but don't
do you know let's get a little bit back
to what the the purpose supposedly of
this bill is which is to protect the
image of women do you think that porn
actually contributes to negative images
I mean she's the one who was a lot of
girls like don't move to Europe that's
first of all European porn is the
craziest point out there like oh yeah
like no I actually have a friend who
does porn it's German porn is the one
area of porn that porn actors in the US
will never ever go to it's like they are
crazy they do more than just [ __ ] on
Wow so maybe as an American here I've
been watching such a vanilla stuff that
I really can't comment
desi you did not we were no you were
signing up every comedian talking about
porn
she seems like a pretty liberal girl I
don't have a problem women yeah I can
see where it's coming from you watch
porn before I mean I I've seen I know
what the psychologists are talking about
when they say that it demeans women and
exploits women I'm just gonna go I would
like to make that one psychologist that
I read specifically referring to this
she said you know porn is a result of
gender stereotypes it is not the cause
of gender stereotypes so that's gonna be
that will not have the effect that
they're hoping people have the morning I
like the watches like the dancing bear
you see that like a guy comes in dressed
up as a bear he's a stripper and like
all these chicks are just taking turns
on them as a like to me that's that's
that's Pro woman you know that's all
like it sounds a hissing Pam I don't
know if it's pro woman it's definitely
answer their phone oboes calm is the
official outfitter of the Rubin report
get this shirt use code trr to zero at
bonobos calm